the girls of the workshop it's great we
don't know how it got mislabeled as
Colombia
[Applause]
oh cool thank you for staying to the
bitter end I'm gonna be talking about
some work that's taken a pretty long
time actually trying to unify a lot of
ideas and machine learning so even at
this meeting it was really nice to talk
by David Cox about predictive coding
models you had Matt Botvinnik and
Collins extra long talk about the
relationship you and working memory and
reinforcement learning
Surya talked about state estimation and
navigation but I think that these tend
to be studied in isolation and we maybe
would profit from studying them together
that would force us also to think about
how these things should interact that's
non-trivial
also when you studied them together more
is different maybe there are constraints
given by one process that inform how the
other processes actually work so this I
think is with the strategy for us to
understand really what the functional
capacities of these systems really need
to be and also gives us working
technology at the end of the day so I'm
gonna talk about some work I've been
doing for some years on neural networks
with external memory to start off and
then how I migrated from working those
networks with external memory to work on
reinforcement learning with neural
networks with external memory actually I
found that to some extent disappointing
so we'll get to that disappointment but
then we'll get to I think an honest
resolution to some extent which is an
agent model it's called the called
Merlin or the memory inference and
reinforcement learning agent so we a
deep mind tend to build tasks and have
agents perform tasks so I'll show you
this thing working on tasks in virtual
reality that are often characterized by
partial durability so all the
information relevant to the agent's
performance is not present in its
sensors therefore you need to have
memory to remember the things that are
needed to make decisions at the given
moment
so I started off working with Alex
graves and Evo Danny halka on systems
that have that are like conventional
neural networks are at least very much
so now long short-term memories but
augmenting them with memory systems so I
think what loves talked about with
allocation being a primitive is
something that resonates with me so this
is a system for example that takes in an
input and there's a conventional
recurrent network but it has extra
output channels that can influence
another system altogether and the other
system is is just a big matrix with rows
so I don't know we you know we we
iterated on this thing and it changed
over time I'll just give you sort of
like the Platonic the simplest one of
these systems so we first called the
thinner alterna Xin and then we called
the differentiable neural computer but
whatever it is it's this matrix plus
this Alice TM and it can do a few things
it can write at every time step so this
works in discrete time and that writing
process is very simple it just a legates
to a new row and reading is also pretty
simple and I'll express that in a moment
you can train these networks by back
propagation methods and they can learn
to recruit this this external memory and
kind of what's kind of cool about them
is that they can do simple kinds of
algorithms with memory so they can do
things like looping they can do process
data structures like graphs and they
have higher capacity memory than the
sort of the simple recurrent networks
and the Alice teams
so the mDM's were just a sort of earlier
more classy version of the DNC's okay so
how do they work you have to define the
mechanism of access memory so for
example reading is a little bit simpler
than writing or actually there used to
be the case but now it's actually maybe
writings more simpler than reading so
you have something called the read key
which is just a vector put out by the LS
TM so it's an extra output channel
that's initially random random vector so
it's a linear mapping from the network
dynamics to a space a beginning
dimensionality that dimensionality is
the same as the size of the length of a
row and you do a dot product against
every row entry and that gives you a
similarity measure okay and that so it's
K times MTI so that's the eighth rows
values at time T okay and that gives you
you exponentiate that and make a
distribution like that I called a
weighting to keep it distinct from the
notion of weights in a neural network
this is a dynamically produced quantity
and we call the detention because well
it seems a little bit like a kind of
gating mechanism and BS everybody else
wanted to call it that too so this gives
you a way of searching memory by putting
a key and then getting a distribution
over the rows of memory and then you can
average the rows of memory have a
weighted average of the rows of memory
and pull out an average value a weighted
average M so that's that's the reading
mechanism basically and this is all
differentiable so the the attention
weighting is a smooth function of all of
the inputs and the network dynamics
all right so at every time step this
system is putting out a read key and
getting out read values and you can
actually have multiple read heads we
called them so you can put out several
Riki's and in parallel look at different
things in memory alright so writing to
memory was at the time complicated but
now it's it's pretty simple so we just
at every time step we take the next row
that's not written to yet so we're
typically dealing with sort of infinite
memories and you can fix that in various
ways but just for the time being let's
effectively consider this is infinite or
as large as it needs to be like a like a
turning tape and there's a vector put
out by this Alice TM as well which is
also the same size as the row length and
it's just inserted directly into the
empty slot so zeros before in this case
that would be 0 initially and then
you're putting in this value and you
just write in row order so you write
that's this is the third time the fourth
time step in the simulation and you're
writing to the fourth row
i thinkin that already that vector
already somewhere above it that way no
you don't do that so if you're writing
the same thing redundant ly it just does
it we worked more recently on a system
that actually based on Penta canner VA's
work that if it were to write the same
thing twice would not write anything at
all it's sort of them but yeah this one
this one writes abundantly now the read
key itself is just the length of our row
so let's call it that the code size say
so it's yeah just so maybe we'll work
with 200 dimensional vectors so the key
itself is 200 dimensional and it's dot
dotted against every row which is 200
dimensional and you have n of these rows
maybe your simulation is by thousand
steps you'll have 5,000 rows and the
matrix basically content you don't have
a separate address it's content-based
addressing which is a good idea okay
cool so anyway D is also the same
dimensionality okay and this Model D is
learned so it's it's learned based on
some kind of loss function so here was
the simplest thing we ever tried which
was a loop problem so on the left hand
side you're gonna get some inputs which
are just random bit vectors in time and
you'll see them for some amount of time
until some sort of flag comes which says
now you're done seeing it just repeat
this now like 10 times and if there's
another flag which says how many times
to repeat it so on the right hand side
is the outputted system which is going
to be a copy of this this pattern and in
the middle you have the memory which is
[Music]
going to be written to buy a write
system row by row for a while and this
is again this is a the NTM which is more
primitive so you can actually see it
writing to multiple locations if you
look closely so kind of ignore to that
weirdness but otherwise it will kind of
write one by one every every pattern and
then it will read them through one by
one you'll see it pretty dramatically
so it does it's writing this is literal
this is actually true this is what we
literally czar it's just a color ization
of it so you this reading out is now
going row by row down and checking all
the patterns times and then it stops and
the important thing was that the LST I'm
network couldn't do this so how do you
build such a system well you you train
it through back propagation through time
at least that the President stated Ark
technologies so at every time step you
get an input X and you produce some
hidden state or recurrent state H which
includes the memory in this case and all
of the recurrent lsdm Network
I mean you bruising output Y and then
you at the next time step inherit some
of your state from the previous
recurrent dynamics from each one going
to h2 but also you get a new input and
so on so that's what unrolling this
graph is like now then you get an error
signal and you back propagate through
this whole chain so you store the whole
systems sort of whole entire trajectory
which is absurd but it is what we do so
then you optimize every parameter in
this model to to make those target
values Y hat more likely you do not
alter the memory but you alter the
parameters that influence the memory so
that the next time around you'll write
different things to memory
so after that like a copy problem we
tried other problems and that was just
the simplest example and I don't want to
go with too much into that this
particular model but the next thing we
looked at was a data structure learning
so we represented graphs random graphs
we would generate random graphs in this
case it's a random planar graph and we
would represent edges on this graph as
source nodes edge labels and destination
labels and those will all be numbers so
every every label has a name which is a
number between 0 and 999 for example and
that would be represented just as 1 not
inputs into the model so you'd get a
vector input at every time step which
says source the edge and the destination
so that would describe one graph edge
and then across time you describe the
whole of the graph and then you ask it
to answer questions so this is an
untrained example which we applied it to
this was the tube and what this problem
is is the traversal problem we called it
so it's basically from Victoria Station
go north on the Victoria Line so after
you've described the entire graph go
north on the Victoria Line and the model
should tell you where you get then go
north on the Victoria Line a second time
where do you get what's the the node
there you go east on the central line
and so on so it should be able to fill
in all the stations along the way and
the way it solves the problem is these
are the locations in memory that are
written one by one
this is the writing it rights to cross
time I guess time is running left to
right here it writes to a location 1
location to location 3 and so on all of
these edges and then when the query
comes in which is of the form it's coded
I guess it's I wish I had a laser
pointer it's it's coded right here it
says Victoria space
Victoria North so it's saying Victoria
is connected to what on when you go
north on that line it happens to be the
station and the station line are the
same
and then it then it does some some reads
of memory that are content-based and its
clever how it does it so what it learned
was this it produces the Alice TM
controller produces Reeb keys right and
these Reed keys actually you can they're
they're abstract and distributed
representations but you can decode them
to those numbers year through 1999 and
then you can say what they mean in your
encoding and there's a from a to and a
lion and the from in the Reed key is the
station you've asked for Victoria
Station the line you can decode and it's
exactly the line Victoria line north but
the read key that the system has decided
to use is empty or undi codable in the
to the the destination and then it looks
up memory and it finds the thing that
has high dot product against this read
vector and it gets a vector back which
is the average of all of those rows
which happens to have filled back in the
answer and then it does that iteratively
going through the entire book traversal
of the graph so that's that's how this
system learns to do content based lookup
ok so then so that's that's how
supervised learning works too so you
train it on you give it examples of
graphs and then you ask it questions and
you make it be give the answers as you
try to make them more likely you'll also
do reinforcement learning with such a
system which I did and I found
disappointing oh but I'll get to that
story so here you have a policy which
produces the action probability so you
have some buttons and you have a random
multinomial distribution over those
buttons and every time so a1 is sampled
from PI of a 1 given the state H and so
on and then the goal of the system which
is what policy gradient algorithms do is
to maximize the return from a given time
point so the sum of future rewards and
the way you do this is you back
propagate in the same way this quantity
which is the return effectively and
there are ways of making this work a
little bit better but it's the return
from a time T times the gradient of the
log probability of that action
probability just action distribution so
make more likely things that are
correlated with return or reward okay so
that's the policy gradient algorithms
now I wanted to apply it to problems
that seemed like they involve memory
here's a simple example the game memory
so we built a little board of amnesty
jets and the agent sees a visual input
at every time which is right now at the
upper left-hand corner with this - and
it's gonna wobble around and then it's
gonna have to remember where it last saw
the same digit so it needs to remember
of what is where to solve this task okay
that's a kind of state estimation that's
the connection to partial observability
in memory all right cool so this didn't
work very well and I'll get to it in a
second so let's consider some
architectures that we'll use to solve
this task so forget this but this is
this is an lsdm with a lot of extra junk
so we're going to apply this to virtual
reality experiments in a minute so
there's a lot of extra sensory data but
for this problem
you basically have to know that there is
an indication of an image that is coming
into the model and there is your last
action which is coming in so you know
your choice is to you know go to one of
sixteen squares and you know where you
went last time and you know what you saw
okay so that's coming in - oh the
observation which is encoded by a system
like
nuts and so on and then that goes into
an Alice TM which is H this recurrent
thing over here these dots mean there's
a recurrence to the next time step of
the simulation so it's a time delay and
then there's a little multi-layer
network that takes in both the memory
state and the embedding that you get
from encoding the stimulus and then you
produce this action probability
distribution the policy and sample and
action that's that's this sort of
standard model if you like so that's
like what Matt Matt Vinick showed the
other day then you can take a DNC or in
neural Turing machine or whatever you
want to call it or just RL mem which now
has an external memory system so it's
the same deal it's gonna get sensory
data it's gonna get an observation and
encode that observation and then it's
gonna interact with this Alice TM loop
over here which itself gets to talk to a
big memory by writing a write vector
into the memory by doing content-based
look up with search Keys and getting
returned values back out
that's that system
so we tried that and those models do not
work very well
I don't mystifying
so the lsdm doesn't work for a good
reason it doesn't have the capacity to
to store a lot of these images and their
locations so this sort of finding of
location and image and doing it for many
of them at the same time is difficult
for the ostium you know it's getting
there at some point but it's incredibly
slow it's painful so I think if we run
this for like the you know you know
months or something like that I might
get there but no who wants to do that
okay so the the memory system actually
paradoxically does worse here you'll see
it do better or later so it's not like
it's not a working system but it's
really not it just it kind of could work
but it just doesn't have the right
objective function is what we're gonna
argue so a score on this is of eight is
solving the task and this a model Merlin
which we'll get to in a little bit
solves this entirely
we'll see how so so I say it's it seems
like the objective function is wrong on
these memory systems so the policy
gradients which you use you you randomly
jiggle around and you get roared are no
easy estimators of of anything the
gradient of the parameter gradient with
respect the loss the grating of a loss
was back to the parameters this is noisy
it depends on this directory so if
there's like no reward in the
environment you learn nothing for
example you get nothing at all so you
only get like chance events that are
pretty rare events are the things that
drive learning but I think more
importantly it's like I'm not even I
don't even care about an argument about
the mathematics because it feels wrong
also so they only learn to remember
things based on trial and error which is
absurd so you see this task is a
perceptual memory task you need to
remember what you saw that's something
that your visual system needs
to be participating in and it should
have nothing to do with what your motor
twitches do at the end of the line so
there's something wrong with m10
learning where you care about the the
action probability is driving your
memory and the development of what the
representations you put into memory so
that's that's sort of the thesis that is
wrong okay but I said to you we're gonna
try to bring things together and that's
what we're gonna do to fix things so
instead of using reinforcement learning
with with random trial and error to
build the representations that we put
into memory we're going to just do
unsupervised compression and prediction
to do it which is I think the kind of
thing that like Jeff Hawkins has been
talking about for a long time and other
people of the meeting okay so so
basically we're just going to do
predictive modeling so that's that's
this paper it's just on archive if you
want to see this it's like a long report
of our studies and I want a credit Alden
hung and Tim Willy crap who is just here
for being my primary collaborators on
this so you could do a lot of methods
for you could use a lot of methods for
unsupervised learning and we just happen
to choose a convenient and modern one
that we're good at so basically you can
think of most of what we're doing is
building auto-encoders but we happen to
use these variational autoencoders so
the variational auto-encoders are
systems to build generative models so at
least most of the people who build
variational on coders somehow care about
building a generative model at the end
of the day which means they can sample
from a distribution that they have
control over like a Gaussian
distribution and high dimensions a
hundred dimensional Gaussian
distribution and then they can produce
something that is cool like an image
that's like their data set so that's
that but that initial sample comes from
something called a prior distribution
and then you produce
a variable Z called the latent variable
and then you push that through a kind of
a decoder which says what's the
probability of an image given Z or it
gives you in basically an image okay but
the way you train this model is you plug
in a lot of actual images X and you
produce an encoding of them into the
same space the same probability space
for Z based on X by a neural network and
then you say okay I really want my
distribution here Q which is a kind of a
Gaussian distribution in this space of
the latent variable Z you want this
distribution to be close to this
distribution and the reason why you want
that so that later on when you sample
from this distribution
it's like sampling from this
distribution which is the distribution
that knows about your data anyway I
think that's gonna be lost on those who
didn't understand it but okay okay so
the loss function of this of this model
basically says make your Q which is
called the posterior like your prior but
also let it reconstruct your data so put
in an image recode it to some space and
then reproduce that image that's the
name of the game and this thing
maximizes the probability of your
dataset essentially okay so that's
that's the this variational auto encoder
model and you can do this in time too so
you can have temporal sequences that are
optimized to and there you get sequences
of latent variable Z so we're gonna have
a model that produces a prediction about
what the next latent variable Z is and
here I've called it a state variable I'm
based on all the previous ones and all
the actions and then there's a posterior
which also gets to see the actual input
perceptual stimulus and produces a kind
of an updated latent variable or state
variable this is actually another
way of looking at bridge of coating a
face so this prior is trained to break
the posterior and the posterior is
trained to minimize its deviation from
the prior but it also wants to propagate
information about the a duration so at
the end of the day the main thing that
you need to take away from this is that
you're getting high dimensional beta in
like images and you're getting out codes
that are 200 dimensional or at low
dimensional from this that still are
somehow information preserving and are
better shaped okay so the this this has
a mechanism so you now have a sensory
data coming in it's gonna be in virtual
reality with image egocentric velocity
the past reward there's actually a text
channel which is used sometimes the last
action and that's all encoded by a
network yours this is now a feed-forward
network and there's a prior which is
predicting what the next code is going
to be the distribution over it and
there's a posterior which updates that
that prior and then produces a sample of
this latent variable a state variable so
this is a recurrent loop here and it's
producing lots of these state variables
that describe the environment you can
use this in two modes one is you can use
it to predict which we're not going to
do although I can show you a little bit
at the end where you run the prior on
its own and it will confabulate
environmental frames so we had trouble
making that work very well I'll be
honest and it wasn't needed to make the
tasks work you could also use this to
just do inference or state estimation to
build low dimensional descriptions of
your sensory data that describe enough
about the environment to make progress
that's what we care about so now so
we're building up complexity and I
apologize if that other bit was
confusing but now we're just gonna do
the same thing which is you know we know
how to build our own ends and now we've
built this RNN that's kind of a the
state estimator system but now we're
gonna add a memory to it so it can store
every one of these state variables in
memory one by one and then it can look
them up by content based addressing with
keys and produce read values
okay so this system can now do things
like say hmm
I see this painting on the wall have I
seen any paintings like it before okay
so this is a two-fold advantage building
system like this one is the state
variables are good representations there
there's information preserving about the
sensory data and they also help
prediction because you've you've stored
a lot of stuff that you've seen so far
then you can use that to make
predictions so if I bend over in that
room already
I can use that information to predict
what I'll see when I go out of that into
that room okay so in this whole system
is trained here to decode or predict the
image the egocentric velocity this R hat
thing which I'll talk about a little bit
more your previous action just to
preserve the information from your
sensory data yeah so the the prior
actually gets the action indirectly so
it its conditioned on the actions
oh cool so that's this is called the
memory based predictor and it it I think
that uh it's something that basically a
lot of people have talked about for a
long time I think so now instead of
doing reinforcement learning in a
standard way what we do is the memory
based predictor is our whole perceptual
system and then the policy is just
something that listens to the
representations that the memory based
predictor produced and to prove that we
don't even back propagate from the
policy into this representations II okay
so this is cool I actually don't like em
tend learning and I like to get rid of
it someday and this is a case where you
can sort of do that you can produce
these perceptual representations that
are low dimensional codes of what you've
seen and then you can just pass them to
the policy and the policy can make do
the policy also reads from the same
memory here that's actually not super
critical actually the main thing is that
it just gets the Z's okay so now we've
just built up stuff so so we've taken
all of the work away from reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is no
longer responsible so much for defining
how to perceive or what representations
to put in memory reinforcement learning
is just responsible for tweaking your
actions
okay so that's what Merlin is that's how
it works
so you can see it operating on this this
was like a really old experiment of a
memory game and it will jump around and
when it sees something it saw before it
will just go back to it okay and you
could do it on fancier images Omniglot
if you like and actually this this one
has even like random perturbations and
rotations show that it's not exactly
template matching when it does it and
here you can see it's roll out so the
the white thing is where it's looking
and the red thing is where it is most
attending to in its memory of locations
that had been previously and to solve
this problem for example on to make one
match to get a point over here it sees
this thing as it sees it it says it
looks up it's in its memory to the point
where it was actually over here which
happened on time sep 3 and then on the
next time step it goes back to the thing
it had seen and gets it gets the match
so it's it's it's jumping around in
memory to be able to find something
that's how previously and then it
actually makes them move to that spot
okay now there's a bit of a problem with
unsupervised learning which I think
people have played with it no and I
think it's most vividly expressed in the
bullet problem so this is space invaders
game and here's a bullet coming at you
let's say you're the guy at the bottom
and that bullet is like really small
it's it's not a lot of pixels so if you
were just to compress data you'd make
compress it away unfortunately your life
depends on perceiving it so what do you
do well yeah that's that's a bit of a
problem so we sort of want to compress
information but keep things that are
kind of tasks rather than goal relevant
and mark Gluck and Katherine Myers
at Rutgers basically they solved the
bullet problem very long time ago in a
paper that was on hippocampal kin
these people doing animal learning
experiments it's really simple so you
could build an autoencoder
that takes in stimuli and then produces
outputs that are the same and compresses
them away or you can build an
autoencoder that also has to predict
something task relevant in this case
what we're going to do is apply the idea
of sort of jointly auto encoding data
but also predicting value or return
information so that's one thing you need
to do to I regret the the slide ordering
this is kind of a mistake okay it's the
other thing you need to do if you want
to scale the system up to work on bigger
problems is use a truncated back
propagation there time so you can't back
propagate through arbitrary lengths of
time so we're never gonna back propagate
through ours I believe a simple strategy
for dealing with this is you back
propagate only over K steps here we set
K to be 20 which is roughly 1.3 seconds
and our simulation so the system is only
assigning credit over 1.3 second
intervals but you'll see that from
memory that doesn't matter if you have a
robust system that's building memories
based on unsupervised prediction it will
just work ok so the thing we've added
though in the clock admirers so these
slides should have been the other way
around is we also predict return even
though return isn't in the sensory data
is it's actually a quantity that comes
from the future
you have to simultaneously decode all of
your sensory data from the compressed
state variable Z and the return so you
have to make a guess about value what's
going to be this the future reward and
that is enough to keep important stuff
around so don't compress away your
bullets if they're coming at you
okay so then we applied this to problems
like navigation so this is an example of
a randomly generated environment and
these graphs are boring but Merlin works
better than the other models so it has
higher score on the top but the
important thing is that it shows memory
dependent behavior so for example the
first time it takes it goes to the goal
it takes a hundred and ten steps and
then the second time it takes on average
60 and the third time so on that means
it's learning about its environment so
this is a I should have said a task
where you have to run around find a goal
and then you're teleported somewhere
random in your environment and need to
get back to it and it's going back
faster and faster each time okay so we
can look at all of the representations
in the model and the memory base
predictor what's in the Alice TM State
with the read values for memory are what
those in this code this state variable Z
and then we can build the simple linear
or maybe it's an LLP decoder actually in
this case of where you are in the
environment allocentric li and as this
thing runs and gets to the goal more and
more times you also get a better
representation of where the goal is in
the environment not where the agent is
but where the goal is in the environment
you can decode that with higher fidelity
here's what that looks like this is what
the agency is at higher res than it sees
it
it's exploring for some time and then it
doesn't know anything so it's value
predictions are up here and it sees the
goal and its value spikes up so it's
like I I'm getting a get reward and then
it starts to predict value over here
let's say so the agent is you can see
about you turning the corner and the
goal is over there and it's predicting a
rising value as if something good is
coming up so it's learned in memory that
this thing is about to come that's
represented here so this agent Merlin
can predict it is lower return
prediction error so it knows things are
gonna good be a good many s'more steps
before the goal before it's the goals
are in sight as lower are about
predicting the actual oncoming value you
can see this on this particular
trajectory that the agents running
around and it's colorizing the amount of
future would reward it's gonna get as
something that's more yellow is higher
and even though it hasn't seen the goal
over here over here it's it's still
expecting more more reward to come so we
can also look at how important this
clock in Meyers trick is which is to
also reconstruct returned information
along with the sensory stimuli and for a
wide range of values the system work so
this is how well the system is doing in
terms of its score on the game and this
is a you know an exponential scale so
there's kind of a wide range of values
of how much you care about decoding
reward based information versus sensory
data
this system works however there is if
there is a sweet spot and you can see is
that you calculate so for example when
the goal is in view you can say what
pixels in the image is this reward value
sensitive to so you take the derivative
of the return prediction with respect to
every pixel in the image and you sort of
say what's the squared magnitude of that
and that gives you these filters which
pick out exactly where the goals are
it's kind of like a dynamic attention
mechanism I don't want to make claims
but I think that's beautiful okay so now
you can train another agent that doesn't
work with the admirers trick so when
you're training your Z's you don't back
propagate from the return prediction the
value prediction but then you plug you
then you sew them up such that you can
back propagate to run this the
particular experiment and this thing is
no longer sensitive to the images so the
value is not it's not a function it's
not sensitive to where the goal is the
same way here's a various explained
analysis is sort of saying you you try
to regress from the input being the
return prediction back to the latent
variable Z and more variance in Z is
explained for higher values of this
return coefficient so if you're asking
the system to care more about reward
prediction or return prediction than
more dimensions of Z are explained by
that the system automatically develops a
kind of hierarchical behavior which is
commute it's easiest to see here so this
is what kind of as a scatterplot where
in the environment the maximum read
value is of one of the heads that reads
memory it's all scattered everywhere it
actually basically follows where the
agent is there's another head though
which is always sort of at the two doors
right in front of the goal and this one
is basically even closer to the goal so
as the system is going around it's
reading from memory if it's been to the
goal already it's reading from memories
associated with the entry points to the
goal where the goal is and right around
itself and you can kind of draw this
like spider thing which is where these
heads are kind of maximally attending to
in the environment yeah
form a memory going around to a place
you can say where was that memory and
then you can say which memories are you
tending to and you can map that back to
the place so I got to the goal and see
this thing is kind of sometimes when
it's far away from the goal it's still
looking at places near the goal
obviously that's just schematic and I
don't expect you to really put much
faith into this so I'm going here I'm
here and I form a memory at this time
point and then I put it into slot 72 and
then I walk over here and I read from
slot 72 and I'm drawing a line from here
over to there this is a working visual
working memory experiment from lies and
Murray called arbitrary vision motor
mapping it's actually in many ways the
simplest of these tasks but it's it's
kind of related so you you see stimuli
need remember in north south east west
how much more time I'll try go quickly I
want to get to some cool stuff so anyway
it learns this task better than humans
do and it transfers to new stimuli sets
here's one shot reward valuation so you
go around and eat some objects that are
randomly generated and you like no this
is good this one's bad the system learns
after kind of one taste how good an
object is and then it does memory reads
back to the events where it was
consuming the object the first time you
can see that but I think custom ran out
of time here's a task that is I just
want to talk about a little bit is it's
a block structured task it's just a
bunch of water mazes and you're gonna
see the same maze at long intervals
between so if you wanna this this
interval between seeing the thing
twice's is so long that it's beyond our
temporal credit assignment mechanisms
beyond backpropagation but our system
since it's just storing information
about the environment locally is
actually able to recall the memories as
needed and solve the task and that
literally breaks every gradient based
algorithm we have
anyway so you could see that working but
read the paper if you wanna so another
last one late and learning the agent
runs around this one's cool I just want
to show this video and then everybody
can go or something so there are two
doors and you run around and collect
apples is the agent and there's top hat
over here and a popsicle over here and
you find out what they are they're
they're valueless in phase one and phase
two you're just doing a distractor task
of collecting apples and then phase 3
you see in a glass case one of the
objects that you were supposed to see
before that you saw before and then you
have to go find it so you this is
learning about the environmental
structure without reward and then using
it later to solve a task so here here
this is actually not really synched with
the top diagram but it's looking at a TV
in phase three and it looks back to a
time point in memory when it was
observing a TV like over here and that's
how it solves the task so it does indeed
solve this this is a important principle
and I'm learning called late and
learning and they can do it to some
extent so let's just watch that because
I think it's really cool so phase one
collect apples phase two is nonsense
just do whatever you want
phase three you need to find the thing
in the glass box
the apples are needed to make the agent
run around admittedly so did you see it
right here so it got out of here it saw
the toothbrush okay and then it goes and
it finds a toothbrush so that's that's
that okay cool
so that's that's the end so we've
dropped an agent model that can solve I
think pretty sophisticated attack the
fastest in these parts desert
environments the principles are to do
perception and memory formation based on
predictive modeling impression last so
by normal than by normal RL we don't
really need to do as much and end
gradient computation so the temporal
credit assignment window here was 1.3
seconds but some of these tasks are six
minute long tasks so we can clearly form
and reuse memories without difficulty
and it can even exhibit types of
learning like latent learning that are
not associated with rewards that can you
know have passive observational exposure
to some event or object and environment
and remember that and I think is
exciting is that it's kind of a
functional model of interacting neural
systems that really does stuff it is
we're not you know these are really long
timescales six six minutes and it's
really getting sensory data that's high
dimensional thank you
[Applause]
this kind of collection I think it's a
pastiche I don't think it really has a
cognitive map I think it really has
found some kind of cool strategy for
sewing together a bunch of memories of
viewpoints into what is needed for
navigating but maybe that's what we do
also to some extent I think that it's
really the jury is still out on how much
of a cognitive map we produce we
construct the rewards if you have a long
system where you have sparse rewards on
that but I don't have an answer for you
explain no friends but I'm trying to
relate not too quick to print
computation it would be right to say
that you ain't really solving really
difficult tasks using a neural net like
components it's maybe a gold standard
high pot assisted Reuter for how say
long term memory could be used for
various whatever what is the goal in
relation to neuroscience is that in
sometimes when you're asking where do
you see the projection so I think it's
really important that we come up with
existence proofs or models that can
produce behaviors that are alike what
brains can produce to have at least some
hanging around and then we can you know
do hypothesis testing so yeah I would
like to have the processes of the brain
the functional outcomes that the brain
produces be
less mysterious and then we can do
things like trained animals on tasks and
train our agents on tasks and see if the
behavior matches up you can look for
actual circuitry that's correlated but I
think to do that you need to first make
sure the behaviors are actually working
right so they need quantification
analytical or at the value studies of
the improvement about 5mm so is they
need quantification analytical or
otherwise right so they're really
knockout experiments that I didn't show
where you knock the memory of it and you
can show that it doesn't work you can do
that actor training which is obviously
very deleterious or you can do that
while training and then it doesn't work
I showed you related models like the RLS
damn that don't work so they're all
experimental results I guess but
another one
you're getting very close to model-based
rld here right but you yourself said if
you use the thing for prediction that
doesn't work is that lots of YouTube the
traditional problem of compounding
errors was there some other problem and
the second question I have is he said
you're very happy that you can train
these modules separately the
decision-making model in some sense on
the perception model for the memory and
that's cool
could you touch it train them joint you
mm-hmm yeah you can train the directing
you get no added bonus so nothing
doesn't matter we have that experiment
in the paper the why is the model-based
rollout in our work the it does work for
like a step but what do you want to do
with that so it's actually kind of my
motto coming in was I'm what can we do
with crappy models I've always felt that
way because we're never gonna have
really great models I just don't think
it's possible especially in partially
observed cases so I'm kind of ecstatic
that it does anything at all and you get
a new kind of model which is a model in
memory so there's a bunch of stuff in
memory that can be queried and so on and
that tells you as much as you need to
know about your environment historically
and the system learns based on trial
performance what to care about in its
model so I I'm more excited about that
now do I think it's not a good idea to
continue to improve the model and see
where you can go I think it would be a
good idea to do that there are technical
things we can do building better
posteriors non-gaussian poster people
and all the stuff that people geek out
on VA use do and also different kinds of
models I think would be exciting and an
indeed you know I don't know should we
do things like dinah or you know
simulated rollouts in memory space I you
know I think there are some problems
where you really do want to do stuff
like that so we're playing around with
things like that we don't have it in
very simple games like this memory game
was really important for us
intellectually like it seems like a
trivial problem but we really figured
out that other models can't work on
and that was important to give us faith
and we're doing like puzzle games with
sort of imaginative planning and stuff a
little bit too so but I don't know I
don't know if I really want to work so
much on making this model that much
better but I think people will do it and
I think that it's a good thing to do
[Applause]